hey guys it's justine and today i'm so
excited because i've got a fun little
video here
some rumor roundups of the next phone
that we have all
been waiting for but before we get into
that a huge thank you to lastpass for
sponsoring a portion of this video
now that we are in new gadget season i
have been using them more than ever to
log into all of my devices that i've
been testing out so i never have to even
try to remember
any of my passwords they do it all for
me lastpass is a password manager so it
will autofill all your credentials on
ios
android and even on your computer it can
also create a strong password
using its generator and it will give you
unlimited password storage
it's so great that you can cross-post
between devices and easily share
passwords through lastpass if someone
else needs to access your accounts this
has been really great for me and my
sister because we do
share some accounts for our podcast so
this makes it really easy to share our
passwords
you'll no longer have to have the same
password for every account but most
importantly you won't have to remember
any of them i'll put a link in the
description if you want to check it out
and thanks again to lastpass for
sponsoring a portion of this video
now let's get into it the question that
everyone has been asking
myself included is when is the iphone 12
going to be announced
obviously at this time last year the
iphone 11 was already announced i think
we even
had it in our hands at this point but
this year things are extremely different
but the news that just came out fairly
recently
the iphone 12 launch date and pre-orders
were just
leaked mark your calendars
the iphone 12 will reportedly launch
october 13th
now i have zero inside information i
know absolutely nothing
all i know is what i googled and this is
what i found
so according to apple insider who claims
to have been contacted
by someone working for a carrier in the
netherlands the iphone 12 will launch on
a tuesday
october 13th so it says this is lined up
with some previous reports that they've
seen i'm checking this out on
tom's guide the same source also says
that iphone 12 pre-orders will start on
friday october 16th and this was based
on
some carrier promos that also had leaked
this was saying that the pre-orders
would end on october 23rd so this would
be one week after
the pre-orders began i mean i guess this
is possible i mean honestly anything is
possible it's 20 20. like
let's just be real another leak that was
found on mac rumors here from a british
wireless carrier
apple is on the cusp of launching its
first 5g iphone models
we are just days away from a major
launch a 5g iphone which would be a huge
boost for 5g
days away okay we're days away if we're
days away
what is it like
how many five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen
item not sure a day is a day days that's
multiple it could be many days it could
really could be anything
mark give us more information so they're
expected to launch four phones so it
seems like there's going to be two waves
of phones the first will be launched in
october which could be the iphone 12
the iphone 12 mini is a possibility of
what they're calling it if they call it
the iphone 12 mini
i'm going to lose my mind that is so
cute
i just can't even handle it an iphone
mini i mean it makes sense you're gonna
have your iphone mini
you're gonna have your iphone not mini
iphone 12 iphone 12 pro
and iphone 12 pro max thumbs up for
iphone 12 mini i'm into it
i love it for anybody that thinks that
this is out of the realm of something
that apple would do
i mean their phone right now this is
called a max they have a mac mini
it's very much inside of the wheelhouse
of something that apple would do
i am all here for iphone 12 mini
there's this comment that says iphone
mini i highly doubt it that's what i
said about the iphone 11 pro max
iphone 12 leak just revealed a bad last
minute surprise
what are you a new says the iphone 12
mini could feature a less powerful b12
chip okay well if you're having a mini
phone
most likely this is not gonna be the
most high end phone
this is going to be something that is
more cost effective this is going to be
a smaller device so the fact that it
might have a lower end chip i don't
think that's
really anything that's that unexpected
and it says right here that this person
does not have an established track
record as a leaker so
get established or get out so here's
some of the leaked iphone 12 specs that
we might be able
to expect so it looks like the iphone 12
pro box is gonna be going up to 512 gigs
like the previous version
i was hoping that they would do a bump
in storage
but i feel like if you get any higher we
would probably be jumping up to one
terabyte
and at that point that's really
expensive and of course the iphone isn't
expandable like a lot of other devices
so i feel like at some point they're
gonna have to jump up to that but is the
time now
we don't know i was also thinking about
how i really wanted the iphone 12 to
have usb-c
i still wanted to have usb-c then i got
to thinking about how much i actually
plugged this phone in
it is almost never i would probably say
i've plugged this in
maybe 20 times over the course of a year
i use wireless charging at night
i get a full battery until pretty much
when i'm ready to go to bed so i feel
like the real apple move is like hey you
want usbc
cool we're just going to remove the port
all together
i really like the new design i like that
they're kind of moving away from the
rounded edges to the more
sharp and kind of just squared off edges
this looks really good this kind of is
taking us back to some previous gen
iphones i'm also excited about the
possibility of the midnight blue
iphone pro the blue aluminum apple watch
i feel like
is kind of a little nod to the
possibility of this color
i feel like at this point that color has
been thrown around so much that it is
more likely than not we will see that
color
as for color choices of the iphone 12
these are some renders here from
everything apple pro i hate kind of
talking about all of these rumors
because i really do like to be surprised
and i think one of the things that apple
has done at least in the past is even
though all of these leaks have happened
there are always things that leave us
kind of like oh my goodness
a lot of people thought the air tags
would have launched with the apple watch
event
but it seems like this is a possibility
for the iphone event so i'm looking
forward to seeing everything that they
have coming up
every day i just wake up and i just
search and hope that today is gonna be
the day and one of these days
very very soon we're gonna wake up and
iphone 12
will be here or at least like a launch
date or an event date like anything
would be awesome i would love to hear
from you guys though what are you most
looking forward to in the new iphone
what do you guys think of the new apple
watch also what has been your favorite
piece of tech that has been announced
over the past few weeks there has been
so much from new consoles to
cameras to phones to drones to basically
everything in between
i would love to hear it leave them in
the comments below and i will see you
guys in my next video
you